denn dass du diesen kuchen jahr ja aber
kommt es zur leinwand sondern zwei
vorherigen wollen da auch ich wollte
so richtig lecker und mehr gut könnte
cancelling verdrücken
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute einen
sommerlichen blechkuchen ich habe
nämlich immer eine galerie geschaut 13
mai 2021 ist so krass das ist über ein
jahr her da habe ich euch so ein richtig
leckeren früchte blechkuchen gezeigt
einfach so auf die schnelle über
instagram und dann hab ich mich nach dem
rezept gefragt und es ist so kann sich
aus bis heute nicht geschafft den für
euch nach zu backen bzw zu zeigen das
möchte ich nachholen ich möchte nämlich
mein versprechen nicht brechen auch wenn
es ein bisschen zu spät ist aber jetzt
ist wieder schönes wetter jetzt könnt
ihr den perfekt vorbereiten passt sowohl
im sommer als auch im winter wenn man
das gute ist man kann ihn mit frischen
früchten machen oder auch mit früchten
aus der konserve ich starte jetzt direkt
hier mit dem flugfähigen teig darf habe
ich meine küchenmaschine und nach den
schneebesen aufsatz vorne dran wir
benötigen jetzt am allerbesten zimmer
waren und geben da gleich auch noch in
lauwarmes wasser mit hinzu und schlagen
das zusammen mit zucker und vanille
extrakt vier bis fünf minuten lang
richtig schön dick cremig
[Musik]
so dass wenn ich meine die cremige masse
heftig wie aus so wenig so viel geworden
ist jetzt winkt sie nochmal minimal ein
das ist normal denn jetzt kommen noch
mehl und backpulver dazu übrigens
schreibe ich euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die
infobox so einfach mit dazu 7
und dann könnt ihr das entweder noch mal
mit der maschine für ein paar sekunden
und herren aber wirklich nur so lange
bis es gerade so vermengt ist oder in
dem durch einen teig schaber aber ich
mache das heute mit der maschine
[Musik]
der teig ist schon fertig und ich
friemel mir mein back ramholt zusammen
müsste einfach so ineinander stecken und
dann stelle ich ihnen ein auf circa 34 x
28 cm
und runter ein backpapier dann kann der
teig eingefüllt werden und ab geht's
dann in den backofen
[Musik]
so der ofens vorgeheizt auf 190 grad
ober und unterhitze und da braucht unser
boden 12 bis maximal 14 minuten und
anschließend vollständig auskühlen
lassen
wir nutzen jetzt mal die zwischenzeit
und machen die leckere creme dafür habe
ich kalte schlagsahne die musst ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank kommen und
ich habe meine schüssel zwar gerade
ausgewaschen mit warmem wasser aber dann
noch mal mit kaltem wasser hinterher
gespült weil auch wenn die schüssel
quasi noch rückstände hat oder warm ist
dann lässt sich die sonne nicht
aufschlagen und dann ärgert ihr euch so
und da gebe ich gleich während ich das
ganze rühre einfach sahne fest mit dazu
und macht dann weiter mit den restlichen
zutaten
[Musik]
so unsere seines schönen stadt
geschlagen die kommt ganz kurz an die
seite und ich habe jetzt hier eine
zweite schüssel da gebe ich einmal
mascarpone reihen die ist super für die
standfestigkeit unser creme er könnte
jedoch alternativ doppel rahmen
frischkäse nehmen ich finde wer die 100
verpasst mascarpone einfach besser und
da kommt gleich noch magerquark dazu und
dann natürlich zucker für die süße ich
gebe noch vanille extrakt dazu und damit
noch mal so einen frischen kick bekommt
einfach nochmal eine bio limette nehmen
und in schalen abrieb und ein bisschen
sagt mit dazu geben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe die masse jetzt wirklich nur
acht bis zehn sekunden verrührt länger
brauchte das gar nicht wollen ja auch
nicht dass das ganze dann zu lange
verriet wird uns wird's ein bisschen
flüssig und noch ein tipp von mir wenn
ihr eine bio zitrone oder eine bio
limette habt verwendet immer wirklich
nur diese hauchdünne schale und sobald
es dann weiß wird unter der farbigen
schale nicht mehr weiter treiben oder
nicht mehr weitermachen weil sonst wird
es bitter und dann wundert ihr euch wenn
ihr euren kuchen fertig habe dass er so
ein bisschen bitteren geschmack hat ich
nehme jetzt hier noch die schlagsahne
und hebt sie mit meinem teigs aber in
drei bis vier schritten einfach unter
die mascarpone quarkcreme und dann sind
wir eigentlich auch soweit wir müssten
dann eigentlich nur noch darauf warten
was unser boden schön abkühlt und die
creme hier in der zwischenzeit einfach
in den kühlschrank stellen
[Musik]
hier ist jetzt alles startklar der boden
ist abgekühlt ich bin vorher nochmal
hier mit meinem backform löser am rand
entlang gegangen aber dann löst sich
eigentlich auch so ganz gut der wird
aber auch ein bisschen kleiner entzieht
sich so ein bisschen zusammen nach dem
abkühlen und daher ist es eben gut wenn
ihre backen hat den ihr dann halt
nochmal gleich so ein bisschen enger
schieben könnt wenn die kleben dazu
kommt aber erst mal möchte ich den auf
meine servierplatten verfrachten und das
geht ganz einfach
ich habe den jetzt hier auch unseren
schneidebrett schiebt das einfach
auf diese vier platten dann könnte das
backpapier da ganz einfach unten drunter
wegziehen am einfachsten ist es wenn ihr
das halt immer rein klappt oder ihr
könnt eigentlich ist es wirklich ein
sehr pflegeleicht attacke könnte
eigentlich sogar im bett kram entfernen
das so in die hand lena passiert echt
gar nichts
sagt einmal umdrehen und könnte mir das
blatt papier unternimmt ist kein solcher
auf der seite liegen bleiben das macht
auch nichts und jetzt den bug rahmen
noch mal drum herum sparen ein bisschen
länger als vorher natürlich und dann
gehen wir unsere cremen drauf und im
anschluss wenn ich das bleibt
verstrichen habe kann ich schon mal die
früchte vorbereiten
[Musik]
jetzt gehts zu den mandarinen die nehme
ich hier aus der konserve und da können
wir den saft ganz gut gebrauchen für die
versiegelung später also für den guss
und deshalb habe ich hier einfach meine
fahne auf die waage gestellt und fang
den saft quasi in der pfanne auf und
dass wir dann später mit agar das ist
dieses pflanzliche geliermittel einfach
zwei minuten lang sprudelnd kochen
gelernt köcheln wird verhängen lassen
belastendes buddeln köche und dann kann
man das später wie gesagt als bus
benutzen das finde ich echt genial
ansonsten solltet ihr nur frische
früchte verwenden dann könnt ihr auch
zum beispiel einfach fertigen tortenguss
verwenden
[Musik]
so jetzt geht's an die früchte und da
könnt ihr auch einfach nochmal mit einem
küchentuch das ganze noch mal so ein
bisschen trocken tupfen damit sie nicht
ganz so voll sind gerade bei dem
mandarin außer dose am besten noch mal
trocken tupfen und dann könnt ihr
einfach die hälfte ihres blechkuchen mit
den erdbeeren und die andere hälfte mit
den mandarinen schön garnieren und dann
kommt auch schon der große obendrauf
[Musik]
also für den bus wege sagt einfach nur
gaga einrühren und zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen lassen danach könnt ihr
das gern noch mal zehn minuten oder 15
minuten beiseite stellen einfach damit
es nicht ganz so extrem heiß jetzt mit
den früchten und mit der sahne in
berührung kommt weil das ist aber nicht
gut dafür und dafür nehmen mich mit
einfach noch ein löffel und dann auch
wirklich ganz vorsichtig weil es ist ja
immer noch lauwarm ganz vorsichtig
einmal über die früchte gießen und
dadurch dass es jetzt versiegelt wird
haben wir auch eine längere haltbarkeit
insgesamt halte also halten die
schnitten ich würd mal sagen drei tage
wenn ihr das dann auch konstant im
kühlschrank kühlt natürlich könnte es
raus nimmt zum servieren aber wenn ihr
das aufbewahren möchte dann auf jeden
fall in den kühlschrank stellen
[Musik]
ich habe einen klick hier sind fertig
ich jetzt damit gebrüstet mich chance
war da noch zu spielen oder sogar ein
bisschen kammerspielen ist seit flecken
bolstern mikrofon darum zuckerschlecken
dass du diesen kuchen jahr
haben wir das auf einer familienfeier
also jetzt auf meine familie mitgebracht
wenn er war so schnell gehör fordern
zwei
folgt dann sagen gemacht dann war
erdbeersaison vorbei dann hätte ich auch
keine lust mehr weil ich wollte dass
frische erdbeeren benutzen ja und dann
kam sache und wenn die nicht ob du bist
die schuldige deswegen haben wir das
nicht gemacht wo mein gott jetzt gerade
jetzt das ist eins machen so klar
vor augen als sie mir gearbeitet hab ich
hab so ein witz gerissen das hat der
kunde gar nicht verstehen der die
zapfsäule regisseur rafi augen ja der
zapfsäule gesucht und mussten und ich so
jetzt haben sie schon vier augen und
wird immer warum ich kann mich ja ich
hab mich kaputt klasse wer war ich nicht
aber das ist eben nur
ein hauch von nichts man kann nicht mal
kam er schon weg bringe so weich ist der
so fluffig dieses stückchen sowieso eine
wolke über aber auch wie leicht es von
der gabel geben und vor allem
normalerweise müssen solche kuchen so
ziehen wenn wir diesmal war aber der ist
komplett frisch gerade gut ja also ich
würde es richtig lecker geht die suche
richtig liegt und naja gut könnte der cd
madrid es ist auch ein weg geebnet weißt
du feuer ich gehe mal davon aus das ist
auch sehr schnell und einfach gemacht
ist
einfach einstellen kuchen zu musste ich
immer also komplett auch chinesen
einfach und schnell macht das nicht nur
auf das haus mit der rechten hand ich
nehme das iphone stellt
man merkt auf jeden fall es ist lag ab
und ich würde sagen mach machen aber ich
arbeite gerne sieht doch optisch so
schön wenn also
fotografieren macht das mal und
allerdings hamburger das leben vom die
fans in echt passaus soll ich wollte gar
nicht gehen lassen aber ihr müsst ihr
jetzt auch das rezept nach machen also
lasst ihr euch jetzt mal gehen und
abonnierten kann dann kostenlos wenn ihr
das nicht schon längst getan habt
gratis content
[Musik]